こんにちは！
はじめしゃちょーです！
はい、というわけで
最後に出したのいつだっけなー･･･
もう結構前なんですけども！
皆様お待たせいたしました！
質問コーナーの･･･
募集動画でえす！
･･･
はい、というわけであのー
なんやかんや
いつも皆さん質問コーナーの質問･･･
あれ？
はい皆さん
えー、いつも質問コーナーの･･･
募集･･･動画･･･
を･･･に･･･
あの、募集ｓ
あの皆さん、いつも
質問コーナーの
質問募集動画にコメントしてくださって
本当にありがとうございます！
いつも本当に
すげーたくさんコメント来るんで
全部見るのがすごい大変なんですけども
それでも僕はやっぱりたらしんぢゃっだ･･･
あの本当にコメントたくさん見るの
すごい大変なんですけども
それでも僕は、あの
その中でもいかに面白いコメントを
見つけるかどうかが大せ･･･
あの･･･
そうなんすよねー
動画のコメント欄をいつも見て
その、面白いコメントを
見つめる･･･
違った
あぬっ、いつもこんっ
･･･メント欄の
あの、コメントを見て
面白いコメントを見つけるのがすごい
大変なんですけども
あの、皆さんの･･･面白いコメント
あの、やべ、何て？
皆さ･･･んの
あの、コメント･･･の
あの、コメント欄の･･･
（焦りは禁物です）
はかせｗ（？）
あの、皆さんのコメント欄に書いてくれる
いつもコメントを見て
あの･･･
コメント欄のコメントを見て
あのー、面白いコメントを見つけるのは
すごい大変なんですけども
あのー･･･
いつも、面白いコメントありがとうございます
コメントの募集期間なんですけども
えーと、今日が５月の５日ということで
５月の中旬、だいたい５月の１５日半ばまで
コメントの、あの
コメントの募集をしようと思います
あの、コメント欄に書く事は本当に
なんでも！
いいです！
あの、中には･･･
･･･
っおっ、質問コーナーと言いつつも
あの、質問コーナーじゃないみたいなとこあるので
もうホント、質問でもいいですし
リクエストでもいいし
あの、僕に言いたいことでもいいし
･･･
文句でもいいです！
文句でもいいし･･･
暴言はちょっと控えめで、お願いします
もう何でも、いいので
えーと、５月の１５日の
２４時まで！
えーと、皆さん
好きなことを
この動画のコメント欄に書いていただけると
僕はっ
あの僕はとなっ
ありがたいと思っております
コメントタイムです
あの、しばらく早口言葉でも言ってみようかなと
思ってるんで
えー、その間に皆さん是非
コメントの方にコメント（？）を
よろしくお願いいたします
東京特許きょっきゃきゃきょ
東京特許許可局！
あっ、言えました･･･
かえるぴょこぴょこ３ぴょこぴょこ
合わせてぴこぴこみぴゅいこぽこ
おぴこ
ふぁ〇く･･･
え？
かえるぴょこぴょこ３ぴょこぴょこ！
合わせえぴょこぴょこ６ぴょこぴょこ！
危ねえ危ねえ･･･
となりの客はよく
かききゅうきゃきゃきゃ
屏風が･･･あ、違えた
おっほええ！
坊主が屏風に上手に坊主の絵を描いた
かえるぴょこぴょこ３ぴょこぴょこ･･･
合わせてぴょこぴょこ"３"ぴょこぴょこ
はい皆さん、動画のコメント欄に
質問、リクエスト
なんか色々、書けることできましたでしょうか？
えっと５月の１５日に締め切って
まあだいたい多分出すのが
えっとー･･･
５月中･･･に出せればいいなと
思っております
えほっ！
うそっ、で５月の１５日まで
えー、皆さんのお餅っ
あ南っ、んのおっ！
コメント
お待ちしております！
バイバイ！！
何なんそれは
【ED】
「青巻紙、赤髪･･･」
「え？青巻が･･･」
「･･･」
「青巻紙、赤ガミガミ、き、きば、きがみ･･･」
っははっｗｗ